non
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public à senna marie george buffet
l'ancien ministre des sports dit avoir
subi des pressions au sujet d'un
contrôle antidopage mené sur les bleus
avant la coupe du monde de football en
1998 c'est en tout cas ce qu'elle a
affirmé sous serment devant la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale qui
travaille actuellement sur le dopage ce
matin je vous propose donc de revoir
cette audition bonne matinée à tous
chers collègues nous commençons notre
deuxième séance d'auditions en
accueillant cet après midi madame marie
george buffet ancienne ministre des
sports et combattante de la lutte
antidopage notre commission denquête
s'est constitué à l'initiative de
jean-jacques lozach notre rapporteur et
de son groupe politique et je dois
madame rappelé que dans le cadre d'une
commission denquête nous devons nous à
ce train là quelques formalités
syndicaux au public qui commence à
arriver nous pour nous rejoindre
qu'aucune manifestation d'approbation
des approbations des possibles pendant
les auditions
j'informe aussi les personnes que nous
auditionnons qu'un faux témoignage est
passible aux termes du code pénal sont
les peines prévues aux articles 434 13
et 414 15 434 15
une pelle de base 5 ans d'emprisonnement
et 3000 euros d'amande
je vais donc vous demander ma nana
ministre de bien vouloir prêter serment
de nous dire la vérité toute la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant je
jure je remercie madame je vous propose
il a commencé l'audition vous proposant
de dire ce que vous avez envie de nous
dire au préalable
et puis ensuite le rapporteur et
l'ensemble des collègues présents et
j'ai remercie parce qu'ils sont nombreux
aujourd'hui nous poserons toutes les
questions qu'ils auront envie de vous
poser
nous écoutons m dont monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs dont
je me félicite de cette commission d'
enquête sur l'efficacité de la lutte
contre le dopage
et c'est bien volontiers que je vais
essayer de répondre le plus précisément
possible à vos questions quelques mots
d'abord vraiment quelques mots d'abord
je pense qu'il faut revenir sur le bien
fondé de ce combat ce n'est pas une
évidence
certains pensent que la pratique du
dopage doit être banalisé et pc quelque
part les rançons du sport tel qu il se
conçoit aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
revenir sur deux raisons fondamentales
de la justesse de cette loi d'abord
l'intégrité physique et psychique des
sportives et 10 sportifs même la loi 99
est une loi de santé publique
en tout premier lieu et ensuite il faut
revenir sur la les valeurs du sport la
question pas simplement de la tricherie
mais aussi des limites des performances
c'est une certaine conception de la
l'humanité de ne pas demander à des
individus d'aller plus loin que ce que
leur corps leur entraînement leurs
possibilités le permet la deuxième chose
que je voulais dire c'est peu la loi de
99,1 surtout fait avancer les choses
parce que elle a donné des structures
indépendantes à la lutte contre le
dopage
lorsque je suis arrivé au ministère
c'est le ministre la ministre qui avait
le dernier mot dans les sanctions il
qu'on le veuille ou non quand vous êtes
un homme ou une femme publique et que
vous devez donc affronter l'opinion
publique en sanctionnant une sportive au
un sportif de haut niveau
vous pouvez toujours flancher parce que
vous avez peur de l'opinion publique ça
m'est arrivé de devoir dire un champion
de très haut niveau qu'il était interdit
de compétition pendant deux ans il a eu
une réaction extrêmement violente et
tant qu'on n'avait pas l'indépendance de
la décision
il y avait risque que le politique ne
tienne pas ce combat
donc je pense la loi 99 s'est déjà donné
l'indépendance de la décision
ensuite c'est le maintien de la sanction
sportive
je vais y revenir mais ça me paraît
important c'est à dire considéré que
quelque part quand même la sportive ou
le sportive est victime
même si les responsables et donc on en
reste à la sanction sportive et on n'est
pas dans la sanction pénale
toujours selon la loi 99 cette loi
n'aura eu aucune valeur en soi si nous
n'y avons pas nous n'y avions pas donner
une dimension européenne
l'europe ne reconnaissait pas le sport
comme une de ses compétences à l'époque
il a donc fallu faire des réunions quasi
clandestine des ministres des sports
tout au début puis des réunions
informelles des ministres des sports et
il a fallu que les états européens face
ensuite une pression positive sur le
mouvement sportif international cio pour
obtenir la construction de l'ama agence
mondiale antidopage et ensuite nous
avons dû à dos et l'ama à l'unesco pour
que la mae autorité sur les pays
il ya certainement aujourd'hui à
revisiter les pouvoirs et les moyens de
la main je pense que cette loi est la
création de l' agence mondiale
antidopage ont permis des avancées
peut-être la première avancée c'est
l'impunité qui a été levée il faut
savoir qu'au lendemain des saisies à
festina sur tour de france 1998 dans le
village du tour
tout le monde pensait que cette affaire
n'aurait pas de suite et un membre du
cio a même dit devant témoins vous
auriez dû prévenir plutôt de
l'arrestation de cette voiture je leur
ait calmé tout de suite en parlant de la
ministre en question
donc il y avait le sentiment que
n'importe comment c'était quelque chose
de banal et qu' on ne pouvait pas
vraiment agir donc on a levé cette
impunité ça je crois que c'est très
important
alors les limites je les dirai il ya
d'abord les lits et stern et si on ne
s'y attaque pas non plus contre le
dopage aura toujours des limites les
limites et stern
c'est les enjeux financiers qui traverse
la pratique sportive
les derniers en date
bien sûr les paris en ligne mais à
partir du moment où on a des
investisseurs qui aujourd'hui achète des
clubs pour le retour sur images
uniquement on aura automatiquement des
pressions sur ce retour sur l'image et
donc sur les résultats on a deuxièmement
le problème des calendriers des
compétitions sportives
il faut que les puissances publiques en
france le ministère il en a le pouvoir
puisse contrôler et réguler les
compétitions sportives ou ne peut pas
laisser aux simples aux seules
fédérations les décisions sur le
calendrier
il faut aller avancé sur le traitement
de l'après carrière sportive
on ne peut pas laisser les individus
régler eux mêmes ce que va être ensuite
leur vie d'homme ou de femme
il faut les accompagner dans cette
construction il faut essayer de l'imiter
mais je ne sais si c'est si ce n'est pas
une utopie
l'instrumentalisation d'état
l'instrumentalisation politique du sport
pour nous en avons un exemple frappant
ce moment avec un état qui utilise le
sport et achète tout un pan du sport et
des compétitions sportives pour avoir
une image un rayonnement international
et on a connu dans d'autres époques des
des états qui faisait un dopage d'état
parce que le résultat sportif était la
preuve du bien fondé des politiques
menées dans ces étapes
il faut aussi faire oeuvre de pédagogie
auprès de l'opinion publique
le comportement de l'opinion publique
par rapport aux performances pousse
toujours à aller plus vite plus haut
plus loin
ensuite il ya les pauses interne qui
limite la lutte contre le dopage
d'abord il ya l'attitude et l'engagement
du mouvement sportif international et
notamment des fédérations
internationales où nous avons un
engagement tout à fait inégal ont fait
pas si telus et y passent que cette
année devant bien sur quel type reer
prix mais je me rappelle dès qu'on a eu
on a osé aborder la question du dopage
dans le football
les réactions extrêmement fort que nous
avons eu de la part de la fédération
internationale de football
nous avons la sophistique sophistication
des systèmes de dopage qui demande bien
sûr plus de moyens pour les laboratoires
et pour les agences indépendantes pour
les contrôles inopinés le nombre les
recherches arrow cherche le suivi
longitudinal dont voilà comment on est
au niveau
je dirais de ce qu'ils en fassent
organise le dopage
troisième problème interne nous notre
loi en france est basée sur contrôle
positif
l'usada a pu confondre lance amstrong
pas par le contrôle mais par les
témoignages par une enquête
c'est une question sur l'avenir de la
loi française nous l'avons toujours basé
sur le contrôle avons nous raison
faut-il évolué pour moi ça reste une
question avant dernière chose
l'encadrement on ne peut pas en rester
aux médecins d'équipé on a un problème
on le voit bien dans toutes les grandes
affaires de dopage du positionnement
d'un certain nombre de médecins
comment on règle la question du rapport
aux médecins à la performance dans les
équipes et puis dernier point la
prévention bien sûr qui est quand même
au point mort et le discours public
ce sera mon dernier point la lutte
contre le dopage et les personnes qui
sont sur le terrain pour agir contrôle
de pages ont besoin d'un discours public
et la dispo politique extrêmement fort
pour les accompagner je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre je passe sans
plus attendre la parole à notre
rapporteur jean jacques lozach madame la
ministre
merci pour votre présence et pour votre
contribution à cette commission d
enquête parlementaire je crois que vous
avez très bien saisi l'évidence par-delà
l'objet de cette commission dans quel
état d'esprit nous l'abordons il s'agit
effectivement de faire progresser la
législation en la matière qui sait
peut-être dans le cadre d'une loi cadre
sur la modernisation du sport telle
qu'elle a été annoncée par la ministre
actuelle pour la fin de l'exercice 2013
et dont vous avez pour le moins apporter
votre pierre à l'édifice dans cette
lutte antidopage à travers votre loi de
et je dirais en termes de dévaluation
après tout ce qui s'est passé à la
lumière de ce qui s'est passé depuis
quel regard rétrospectif quelle
évaluation vous portez sur ce texte de
regrettez vous de ne pas être allé plus
loin dans un certain nombre de domaines
une deuxième question vous avez évoqué
de manière plutôt implicite un certain
nombre de pressions que vous avez subi
lorsque vous étiez à ministre pour
limiter les interventions dans cette
lutte contre le dopage est ce que vous
pouvez
justement nous nous préciser les choses
en ce qui concerne les pressions qu'ils
pouvaient s'exercer à ce moment là
comment est bien évidemment de qui
venaient ces pressions épine petit
complément de précisions sur la fin de
votre intervention puisque vous avez
évoqué le football vous avez été
ministre de 97 à 2002 la france a
organisé et gagné la coupe du monde de
football en 1998
est ce que vous considérez que l'équipe
de france en 98 a été épargné entre
guillemets en ce qui concerne les
contrôles antidopage comme l'affirment
certains notamment dans la presse merci
monsieur le président mais le rapporteur
sur un regard rétrospectif sur la loi
elle-même proprement dit
mon seul questionnement aujourd'hui
c'est peut-on rester simplement à
l'élément du contrôle faut-il élargir la
lutte contre le dopage par jeudi j'ai
envie de dire un processus policiers
voient la ccim si vraiment l'âme à ma
question je crains que ce processus
policiers entraîne
dénonciations abusives entraîne des
maladies et suspicion permanente toute
une série de choses donc c'est
extrêmement risqué c'était seulement
risqué mais on s'aperçoit hélas les
événements ont montré que c'était
nécessaire dans certains cas pour
démonter des systèmes de dopage qui sont
très perfectionnés qui sont très
sophistiqués sur la loi je pense que
c'est ça le ma seule question sur sur
les pressions les pressions elles sont
de plusieurs ordres
il ya d'abord la pression gens me dire
de l'opinion publique en elle-même
pendant le tour de france 98 et certains
d'entre vous ici l'on véhicule très en
direct des élus des dix et mais tu
tiendras pas le pin et au public va se
retourner contre toi donc ces
dépressions je l'appellerai général des
pressions plus précise oui vous parlez
de l'équipe de france de football
lorsque nous déclenchons un contrôle sur
l'équipe de france de football qui est
en préparation à tignes
j'ai tous les médias qui me tombe dessus
de façon très violente puisque je
j'empêche que l'équipe de france se
prépare dans de bonnes conditions
il ya un déferlement médiatique il
faudrait retrouver le nombre d'émissions
consacrées à cela et la façon dont on a
parlé à ce moment là de ce contrôle
inopiné
je vous le dis à ce moment là dans les
heures qui ont suivi j'ai flanché
je me disais mais est-ce que j'ai pas
fait une erreur est ce que j'ai gt gt
mis au bon vraiment et j'ai eu le
sentiment que on était complètement
isolé et qu'on était condamné par
l'opinion et est pas parce qu on avait
envoyé vous n'avez perturber l'équipe de
france de fond dans sa préparation coupe
du monde
l'autre moment où il ya eu des pressions
les plus fortes c'est au moment des
candidatures pour les jeux olympiques
puisque la première candidature pour
paris 2008 qui était dirigée par
monsieur verbruggen président de l'uci
mais membre à part entière du seo et
donc président cette délégation et à
l'époque pour nous les pressions se sont
exercées par l'intermédiaire monsieur
vers bologne mais également d'autres
membres du cio
monsieur qu'il y ait les potes et
monsieur de russes ont été entretenues
auprès du premier ministre en me
demandant de faire une lettre précisant
que la loi française ne s'impliquerait
pas dans sa totalité moment de la tenue
des jeux
j'ai été convoqué à matignon 2 pour
discuter du contenu de ce courrier et
nous avons convenu que la france s'il y
avait un code mondial du dopage
si donc l' agence mondialité mise en
place il y avait un code mondial du
dopage bien sûr la france s'adapterait
sa législation à ce code mondial ce que
nous avons fait son monsieur l'amour qui
était ministre
lorsqu en effet on a adapté à juste
titre notre législation au code mondial
antidopage
c'était une pression extrêmement forte
on a remis donc la nette qui contenait
cela à monsieur verbruggen en haut de la
tour eiffel puisque pour sauver la
délégation de la tour eiffel je m'en
rappelle mais pendant l'audition de la
délégation française à moscou monsieur
le premier ministre ne naît jospin a été
interrogé je crois à trois reprises sur
la même question donc la pression s'est
exercée sur la france jusqu'au bout et
lorsqu'il ya eu la candidature de paris
2012 un représentant de cette
candidature avait eu cette phrase je me
rappelle d'un interview je ne sait plus
sur quel média en disant mais paris 2012
se présente mieux que paris 2008 parce
que paris 2008 il y avait eu quand même
le problème de la lutte antidopage et on
a vu que c'était moins la lutte
antidopage que les intérêts des sponsors
qui disent qu'ils faisaient que telle ou
telle candidature était retenue par le
ceo puisque paris 2012 a été de la même
façon de paris 2008
battus donc oui dépression et exister je
trouve que l'opinion publique
dans toute cette période a plutôt bien
tenu et que j'ai pu retourner sur ton de
france sans me fait sortir du tour de
france je trouve que l'opinion publique
a plutôt bien tenu mais ce sera toujours
une lutte on sera n'importe comment sous
la pression parce que aujourd'hui le
sport ce au delà des problèmes
financiers il ya un tel une telle
instrumentalisation du sport au plan des
plans des états ue plan politique que
nous aurons bien sûr toujours à
combattre ces pressions merci je puis le
oui
raismes la ministre je voulais vous
poser une question qui peut rebondir sur
vos derniers propos tout ce que vous
venez d'évoquer ses c'est le sport de
très haut niveau c'est le sport qui
passent à la télévision c'est le sport
spectacle spectacle en portent souvent
sur le sport ce qui m'inquiète
personnellement ce qui m'a déjà amené
d'ailleurs à poser des questions sur ce
point c'est les jeunes poussent les
jeunes
je m'inquiète beaucoup de voir comment
on peut psychologiquement les préparer à
l'acceptation du dopage
certes j'utilise pas du produit dopant
on peut imaginer dans le sport spectacle
je suis toujours un peu stupéfaits de
voir qu avant une compétition sportive
de tous genres de l'athlétisme tennis
football rugby pour les adolescents on
puisse vanter
certains produits en vente libre alors
je vais en citer je sais pas si
d'ailleurs ils sont six co logiquement
plus de ponts créé le mans mais le temps
bulle des boissons énergisantes des
cocktails de vitamines
peut-être d'autres recettes locales
ce qui me choque c'est que ce faisant
les prépare psychologiquement à une idée
qu'on puisse aller plus loin qui sont
propres physique et je voulais vous
poser la question en ce domaine
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire vous avez
bien les volets qu'est le volet de la
prévention mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour sauver les jeunes pousses et
tant pis pour le sport spectacle et
deuxièmement dernier point c'est
peut-être plus technique mais qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un produit dopant un
produit dopant
ça peut doper que le mental ça peut
doper aussi le muscle le physique
à partir de quoi on devient un produit
dopant est ce que ce n'est pas plutôt
dans une pratique parce que l'alcool
peut dans une certaine mesure avec une
certaine dose mesuré est un pro est un
produit dopant
alors je me pose toujours la question de
savoir quand est-ce qu'on est propre
d'abord sur la pratique du dopage
tant que j'ai eu en main les
statistiques des cas contrôlé positif
on s'aperçoit que ça traverse toutes les
pratiques amateurs comme professionnels
haut niveau comme sport pour tous et
tout ça faut l'avoir en tête font
l'avoir en tête
moi je me suis je me rappelle en 98 je
fais un débat avec des collégiens des
lycéens dans une ville sans questions à
leurs dons une question qui ils sont là
sur le moment j'ai pas compris ce que
disait le petit garçon ils disaient mais
pourquoi on nous met des cachets
effervescence où la langue
lorsqu'on rentre sur le stalles et puis
je passe à une question que je m'arrête
d'un seul coup je dis oui j'ai pas
compris donc je repasse la parole aux
petits garçons
et en effet il ya eu que ce soit par les
boissons énergétiques mais aussi par
d'autres méthodes
on explique aux jeunes sportifs pour
aller au bout de la performance il faut
se faire aider
voilà alors après ça peut être des
choses on dit c'est pas dangereux parce
que c'est un aspirine effervescents donc
c'est pas dangereux c'est pas ceux ci
sauf que c'est simplement l'accoutumance
à se dire qu'il faut prendre quelque
chose pour réussir la performance
et quand vous lisez vous lisez des
écrits je pense par exemple à un homme
comme christophe bassons prix les prix
et qu'il explique l'ong deux jours qu'il
faut en entrant à l'épaule dans une
équipe pour être tous mis de côté ou
admis dans l'équipe parce que vous êtes
c'est bien cette année de pratique
voilà c'est donc très vite vous êtes
amené à vous accoutumer faut faire un
choix et qu'il faut vous y allez quoi
donc je pense que quand je parle de
prévention c'est au niveau de tout ce
qui est l'encadrement du mouvement
sportif
c'est là dessus qu'on peut mieux jouer
je pense il faut bien sûr alerter les
jeunes les enfants ou ses tirs amis
s'ils sont pris dans un entourage qui va
aller petit à petit les années c'est
section encadrement qu'il faut jouer et
ça ça passe à la fois par le ministère
et ses personnels qui peuvent jouer un
rôle mais ça passait énormément par le
mouvement sportif énormément par une
volonté du mouvement sportif de faire ce
travail de prévention à l'intérieur même
de ces deux fédérations
je ne vous suis pas c'est le sénateur
sûr tant pis pour le sport deux
spectacles parce que non non non je sais
parce que faisons attention que ce soit
au point de vue financier comme au point
de vue du dopage
il faut surtout pas dire qu'elle et
débrouillez-vous là le sport spectacle
parce qu'ils vont se débrouiller mais
pour le plus grand malheur du sport en
général parce qu'il l'exemple sera
toujours là il se sera un exemple de mal
en pis donc il faut surtout pas laisser
se débrouiller il faut il faut continuer
à oeuvrer pour réguler sport
professionnel le sport de haut niveau
vous continuez vous pas les laisser
partir ou ce qu ils veulent partir tout
seul faux pas les séparer
c'est extrêmement important de le tenir
et de les réguler je je je crois alors
comment définir un produit dopant
si je vous répond de façon
institutionnelle jeudi je respecte la
liste des produits d'automne dopants
émis par l' agence mondiale antidopage
et j'en ressens pas si vous me permettez
madame alice je ne veux pas vous
interrompez on reçoit à partir de demain
certain nombre de médecins et donc c'est
pas une question qui vous concerne
directement si vous souhaitez nous dire
des choses alesi bien sûr préféré mois
la liste des produits dopants
élaboré par des gens capacité de travail
que je ne suis pas en capacité qu'on
aura donc l'occasion de poser des
questions plus précises au médecin du
sport que nous verrons à partir de
demain n'est ce pas monsieur dufau
ancien rapporteur d'un texte merci le
rapporteur à l'assemblée nationale dans
une vie antérieure voudra lui aussi
s'exprimer après mais il fait comme il
veut c'est du faux à la mélamine
il se trouve que j'étais déjà là en 99
que j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans le cas
d'un commission des affaires culturelles
du sport sur votre loi qui a
véritablement donné le départ
l'impulsion une vraie lutte organisé au
niveau de l'état qui compteront dommage
puis j'ai suivi toutes les étapes en
particulier les avancées significatives
donné par les lois de jean françois
lamour qui encore amélioré donner
beaucoup plus de pouvoir la fédé et qui
encore amélioré si les compétences du
laboratoire de châtenay malabry
c'est vrai qu'on a fait des progrès
considérables je vous ai bien écouter
sur les pistes qui comme monnaie de de
suivre pour essayer d'aller encore
beaucoup plus loin il ya quelques unes
ce qu'elle je suis tout à fait d'accord
en particulier la régulation par les
fédérations des calendriers ça me paraît
fondamental et quand on parle cyclisme
on sait très bien qu'il faudrait réduire
la durée du tour des journées de repos
supplémentaire et réduire certains états
et c'est pas possible de continuer à
faire un tour qui a mais autant de
difficultés en si peu de temps c'est
évident il faut des produits si on veut
arriver
la figure en bonne place dans la la
c'est un vrai problème
je pense qu'il faut aussi continuer à
travailler sur les invités à beaucoup
trop d'abus les autorisation à usage
thérapeutique thérapeutique qui
permettent effectivement de masquer
beaucoup d' utilisation de produits
dopants
en fait sur votre idée d'aller au delà
des contrôles je pense pas que ce soit
souhaitable parce qu'effectivement ça
ouvre la porte à toutes les dérives
y compris les témoignages des
témoignages bidon volontaires faux
témoignage pour mettre en difficulté
certains mots ça c'est très délicat
je crois qu'il faut travailler sur la
qualité du contrôle aller plus loin
contrôles inopinés et c'est bon je pense
que la fête des fêtes était bien son
boulot encore phonétique toutes les
grandes fédérations sportives acceptent
ces interventions ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas l'autre jour on a vu
roland garros a discuté le président
on sait très bien qui ils n'ont pas leur
rentrée à roland garros voilà alors
juste un point cousin pas évoqué
peut-être intéressant c'est qu'est ce
que vous pensez de la généralisation du
passeport sanguin l'analyste
merci monsieur le président pour les
autorisations usage thérapeutique
j'avais été je m'étais rendu sur 98 je
pense 97 peut-être sur un championnat du
monde qui se déroulait en france où il y
avait plus de 50% d'asthmatiques
d'asthmatiques non mais la cité pas le
ton ce n'était pas le cyclisme il y
avait plus de 60% d'asthmatiques avec
ordonnance
donc c'est un véritable problème qu'il
faut traiter mais ça ça rejoint ce que
j'ai dit sur le rôle des médecins dont
les fédérations dans les équipes si on
excusez-moi si le mot la phrase est
peut-être eu depuis si on ne
ne travaille pas sur cette question des
médecins des équipes on va pas régler
les problèmes parce que s'ils sont dans
un état d'esprit d'accompagner toujours
plus sa performance automatiquement
voilà on est dans le autorisation à
usage thérapeutique et puis ensuite
d'autres choses
cholet fait la fld le problème qu'on a
c'est mais ça c'est la main qui peut qui
devrait travailler à cela en lien avec
le seuil haut c'est qu'il faut obtenir
des fédérations internationales que ce
soit les agences qui contrôle sur sur
les épreuves qu'elle organise il faut
retirer du pouvoir de contrôle aux
fédérations internationales absolument
pas ce qu'on prends toujours l'exemple
de lucie n'y a pas que si regardez
toutes les compétitions internationales
qui ont lieu sur notre territoire et
c'est un véritable problème mais ça
c'est pas la loi française qui peut le
faire cesser un travail de ces une
bagarre excusez-moi a mené par rapport
au comité international olympique
c'est là les états avec la main elle
part de excusez moi je crois que tout ce
qui est suivi longitudinal nous est
quand même à détecter aide à détecter
les situations anormales aidons à mieux
cibler ensuite les contrôles c'est quand
même une aide à faire un travail plus
efficace de contrôle merci messieurs le
lot scouarnec
je suis bien entendu très intéressant
par rapport aux puissances d'argent donc
je suis quand même très inquiet
puisqu'il ya de plus en plus d'argent
n'ose pas on voit le football mais il
n'y a pas que le football derrière la
séquelle comment lutter contre parce
qu'à mon avis on peut pas lutter de
manière efficace quant aux deux passions
s'en prend pas un peu à la loi de
l'argent dans le sport alors en plus
maintenant et les états qui achètent des
clubs donc ça n'arrange pas les choses
s'étaient déjà sur la mauvaise pente
avant mais nécessaire à une aggravation
et la mondialisation tout à l'heure tu
parlais de l'europe évidemment très
intéressant de travailler au niveau de
l'euro mais ce que c'est suffisant
aujourd'hui
et par ailleurs en parlant d' enquête de
contrôle je pense que le contrôle un
côté scientifique que la roquette n'a
pas forcément
alors peut-être que l'anc est peut être
envisagée uniquement pour pour compléter
suite à un contrôle
mais s'il n'y a pas de contrôle au
départ et qu'on passe au dessus d'elle
enquête à mon avis là on prend peut-être
des risques et il peut y avoir des
dérives dalibard ailleurs un taux de
france raisonnable et profil humain qui
peut le de déterminer le déficit et
faire en sorte que ça a évolué dans ce
sens et non pas 20 monter des cols vous
n'est jamais passé encore 4e cat et hors
catégorie évidemment le plus possible
des longueurs d'étape quelquefois un peu
le même à l'arrêt ce que je sais pas si
il les calendriers donc intervenir sur
la carrosserie qui doit être sur les
fédérations qui ont le pouvoir c est ce
qu elles vont évoluer vers ce faire ça
je sais pas voilà merci le ministre
merci monsieur président oui c'est pour
moi c'est moi l'épreuve elle-même
par exemple le nombre de cols dans le
tour de france que sur une année sur une
saison sportive le rythme des épreuves
auxquelles participe le même sportif je
regardais puisque j'étais d'habitude
attentive à ce qui se passe dans le
rugby est donc j'étais au stade samedi
soir on regarde le nombre de matches de
rugby effectué par certains des joueurs
de l'équipe de france de rugby alors
qu'on sait que le rugby redemande une
récupération importante compte tenu du
sport lui-même
on peut se dire que c'est trop demander
à certains de ces rugbyman bon alors ce
rythme des compétitions
le ministère a moyen pour les
compétitions nationales
à travers la législation mais à travers
tout simplement ses rapports
institutionnels avec les fédérations le
l'agrément les conventions et c'est de
poser
reste les cadres et les calendriers
internationaux où là c'est pas la loi
française ministère tu peux qui peut
régler ça
là aussi c'est c'est la maille et le
sillon qui sont opérateurs là dessus par
rapport aux puissances financières paris
en ligne ces terrains fonds de pension
parce qu'il n'ya pas que il n'ya pas que
les états à cachette des clubs il ya
aussi maintenant des fonds
d'investissement il faut pension chez
moi j'en étais venu à l'idée qu'il
faudrait qu'on soit capable au niveau
atteint de façon internationale de
mettre en place une structure
équivalente à l'ama agence mondiale
antidopage qui serait en charge de la
régulation financière dans le sport mais
il faut que ça soit un organisme
international du même style que la masse
c'est-à-dire où il ya le mouvement
sportif et les états
quand on a parlé à l'origine de la main
vous l'appelez pas comme ça à l'époque
tout le monde nous disait c'était une
utopie qu'on n'y arriverait jamais puis
finalement il y avait des obstacles pour
rappel au début la position des états
unis d'autres états c'était bon et on a
réussi à la mettre en place
quand je dis on c'est plusieurs états
qui se sont battus et c'était vraiment
et je pense que pour la régulation
financière dans le sport il faut aller à
un organisme international
on a quand même une situation qui est
étonnante dans le paysage institutionnel
international
c'est ce mouvement sportif qui n'a aucun
contrôle ou plan international chaque
état essaye plus ou moins la france plus
que d'autres états de contrôler et de
réguler mais on est une exception dans
le paysage institutionnel international
nous sommes une exception ce partage des
missions publiques entre l'état et
moment sportif c'est une déception donc
ce mouvement sportif vie en lui-même son
contrôle extérieur au plan international
donc je pense qu'il faudrait que ce
qu'on a fait sur le dopage avec la
maille
faudra le faire au niveau de la
régulation financière si avant de passer
aux intervenants suivants je voudrais
revenir un instant sur un élément de
votre présentation liminaire
vous avez évoqué la coupe du monde de
football de 1998 il y a dans un ouvrage
les scandales du sport contaminé un
auteur eric maitrot qui a affirmé que
l'équipe de france aurait été où a été
épargné par les contrôles à la demande
de jeunes c'est qui paraît-il qu'il
écrivait la demande du ministère des
sports
que pensez vous d'une telle affirmation
et et sont ceux des choses que l'on doit
considérer comme vrai de la part de cet
auteur moi ce que je peux dire c'est que
nous n'avons jamais donné de directive
en ce sens au ministère des sports
ensuite il faut se replacer dans
l'époque nous sommes à la coupe du monde
il n'y a pas d'âge ans va les opposer
pas la langue c'était le conseil
national de lutte contre le dopage il
n'y a pas tout cela nous ne sommes
absolument pas dans la situation avec
les outils que nous avons aujourd'hui
nous avons les contrôleurs du ministère
c'est tout ce que nous avons entre les
mains danse est un problème de
d'éléments inadéquat pour effectuer les
contrôles
il ya pas toute l'organisation qui
existe depuis que vous et vos
successeurs ont pris des décisions non
elle mange le sens de l'organisation des
contrôles
je le dis tout à fait franchement le
seul moment où j'ai senti que je flanche
et parce que j'ai la pression était trop
forte c'est après le contrôle inopiné de
tignes où j'ai presque été amenés dans
les radios à m'excuser mais après il n'y
a pas eu de directive en ce sens mais
nous sommes nous étions quand même avec
nos contrôleurs point final les
contrôleurs internationaux de la fifa
merci un autre rapporteur mais devant
une autre assemblée
jc à l'époque de l'assemblée nationale
messieurs merritt neri oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mais ma députée c'est sûr est question
ce cas a beaucoup travaillé et on s'est
aperçu qu'il ya deux aspects croix dans
la lutte contre le dopage
il ya l'aspect éthique et l aspect santé
sur l'aspect éthique
je crois que deux choses en a parlé on a
raison de parler du problème de l'argent
mais il ya aussi le problème de la
nature humaine presque tout le monde a
toujours envie d'être guide de gagner
d'être le premier et il ya une espèce de
gloriole ce qui fait que le dopage
on le voit au plus haut niveau mais on
sait malheureusement que certains pour
aller faire le match de tennis contre le
voisin et pour pouvoir dire que il a
battu le voisin ou parce qu'en course à
pied il est allé plus vite que non même
dans une sans compétition il y à cette
volonté de deux puissances y est on peut
dire que certains moments cette volonté
de puissance
certains se posent la question de dire
mes moyens naturels mais ne me
permettant pas de réaliser mes désirs
je vais me faire accompagner par des
moyens qui sont des moyens illicites
alors moi je crois qu'à ces deux
questions là sur le point de de la
régulation des moyens financiers il
croit qu'une chose qui se pose c'est
l'organisation mondiale du sport parce
que tout le monde sait bien que nous
avons été premier en france et dieu sait
si on s'est fait quelques ennemis
intimes à l'époque quand on a dit qu'on
changer le statut des clubs sportifs et
que deux clubs du statut associatif on a
on est passé aux sociétés objet sportif
qui permettent effectivement un meilleur
contrôle des flux
mais certains pays au monde n'ont pas ce
système là donc à partir de là y'a aucun
contrôle qui peut se passer y compris au
nid
des transferts ce sera notre sujet donc
je crois que vous avez raison il ya un
véritable problème de régulation des
moyens financiers deuxièmement sur les
problèmes de d'éthique
moi je crois que à partir du moment où
on veut que le sport soit un élément du
développement de la personne et ça doit
aussi être le développement certes
physique le développement intellectuel
mais aussi développement moral et je
crois qu'on a toujours dit que le sport
ça devait être l'école de la vie donc la
pète l'école de la vie où on triche
ce don contraire être l'endroit où on
apprend à respecter la règle de la
nécessité d'avoir des règles et puis je
pense que il faut réguler les saisons
vous avez raison quant à la dudh et
compétitionner la compétition elle se
fait en fonction des moyens qu'on a
moi je veux parler de ce que je connais
un petit peu plus qu'une reste sur une
compétition cycliste
où peut bien mettre quatre ou cinq cols
ou s'y colle mais ça n'a rien à voir
parce que les coureurs par eux mêmes
font la course en fonction des
difficultés
ouais bien que quand on fait des heat
après quatre ou cinq cols des fois les
deux trois premiers cols ce monde
tranquillement parce que on fait
l'effort après les étapes longues elles
étaient encore plus longue et elle n'est
pas qu'on parlait pas du dopage
sophistiqués comme les moi mon père a
fait le tour de france en 1947 la
première étape c'était paris lille la
deuxième étape c'est elle et bruxelles
la troisième et à bruxelles luxembourg
pour percuter et pourquoi mais la course
c'est pas du départ et c'est autrement
et et quand on avait les abdos colle les
états par an elle se faisait gentiment
parce qu'on se réservait pour établir
une autorégulation du sportif c'est
justement parce qu'à dopage qui a pu
cette autorégulation et qui peuvent
faire quelques exercices qui sont
au-delà de ce qu'on peut penser nature
et donc moi je crois que là-dessus il
faut être clair il s'agit du voir une
régulation des saisons et en particulier
la mondialisation du sport amène
aujourd'hui qui a plu
mais la saison n'est toute l'année dans
tous les sports tous les sports on joue
au rugby dans l'hémisphère nord à faire
une pige dans l'hémisphère sud était là
et c'est encore pour des questions
effectivement autres moi je crois que tu
suives faut être très clair il faut une
régulation au niveau des fédérations
pour les saisons faut une régulation au
niveau de l'organisation sportive sur
effectivement organisa et pour la
question troll de la santé excusez moi
les deux solutions pour l'un pour le lui
lusage l'utilisation thérapeutique de
solutions où je suis malade ou je suis
pas malade
si je suis malade ben je suis un sportif
professionnel je suis à ce moment là un
arrêt de travail comme tout tout employé
malade mais csu amateur
quelle importance que je fasse pas
l'épreuve puisque je suis amateur et que
c'est pas ma profession donc il faut
défendre absolument empêcher
l'utilisation thérapeutique je sais
c'est la porte ouverte à la tricherie
éhontée la spock et du monde
deuxièmement sur le les contrôles
inopinés attendait pourquoi on s'est
battu dans la loi pour le contrôle
inopiné
tout simplement parce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui faire les dopages retard et
qu'on peut me doper aujourd'hui et
j'aurais un effet d'un site dans trois
mois on 3 plus rien donc ça c'est
absolument adapter la lutte antidopage
aux progrès scientifiques qui sont faits
dans ceux qui pratiquent le dopage pour
je crois qu'il faut le courage d'aller
jusqu'au bout là dedans de dire oui les
contrôles inopinés
oui condamner les autorisation à usage
thérapeutique parce qu'on la sait plus à
peine de faire contrôler son atelier ça
et puis moi je pense qu'il ya ce
problème de la santé publique est
essentiel et je serais assez favorable à
ce qu'on engage jeu parce que j'entends
c'est bas de la ministre mais qu'on
engage pourquoi pas une étude
épidémiologique pour savoir quelle est
la durée de vie des sportifs drôle oui
parce qu'on sait personne la discipline
quand on a quelques difficultés à
accepter des disparitions trop précoce
merci à madame la ministre monsieur
mairie sur une étude épidémiologique sur
la durée de vie des sportifs et
sportives il faut faire attention plan
éthique comme on pourrait mener cette
étude on sait que la pratique forte du
dopage a souvent entraîné chez des
sportifs on avait fait des études là
dessus à l'époque une dépendance ensuite
à d'autres formes de cyclos manie cetera
parce qu'il y avait besoin de prise de
deux médicaments
la majorité des pays qui autorisent les
paris en ligne
non aucune agence de contrôle de séparer
il faut savoir c'est ça la réalité de la
situation
la majorité des pays qui autorisent les
paris en ligne you les paris en ligne
sur les plus nombreux n'ont aucun en
lice mme de contrôle
donc nous bien sûr on contrôle la mine
autres agences très bien la rebelle elle
fait du bon travail mais excusez moi la
revel elle prend ce qu'elle a pris
récemment qu'ils sont des bons c'est pas
des c'est pas des grands trafics
voilà donc quand alors on peut se dire
est-ce qu'il ya capacité
d'autorégulation du mouvement sportif
international par lui-même mon intime
conviction et non mon intime conviction
et non c'est pas lui c'est pas en disant
ça je ne sais pas une critique entre les
hommes et les femmes qui composent ce
grand sportif mais le sisp le
fonctionnement même de ce mouvement
sportif
au plan international la façon dont ces
organismes de direction sont sont
construits font qu'il ne peut pas s'auto
réguler rappelez-vous début de la
présidence de monsieur rogge il a essayé
sur une question d'assurance par exemple
il s'est fait battre façon très sèche
conseil d'administration dont qu il ne
peut pas y avoir d'autorégulation donc
la puissance publique doit intervenir
dans cette régulation
même si elle a besoin du mouvement
sportif pour l'accompagner mais la
puissance publique doit intervenir dans
cette régulation je ne vois pas tout
seul
merci merci d'avoir remarqué qu'en
france est déjà un embryon en la matière
et que la volonté c'est d'obtenir une
organisation au minimum européenne en la
matière je peux vous envoyer un
excellent ouvrage qu'il rapporte que
j'ai pondu ya quelques semaines là
dessus dominique bailly
oui mais la ministre je m'inscris dans
la dans la conclusion de votre dernière
intervention effectivement il me semble
que les fédérations ne sont pas assez
impliqués dans cette lutte et à la
volonté politique forte vous l'avait
incarné vous l'incarnez encore un mois
je me demande je m'interroge comment
justement pourrions-nous dans un rapport
de force
mettre les fédérations vraiment dans
cette même dynamique il y as certaine
gouvernance certaines fédérations qui
ont bien saisir l'ampleur du problème
qui sont volontaires mais d'une manière
globale on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement
c'est là
cette articulation qui peut faire défaut
un certain moment alors avec votre
expérience
comment mettre en place ce rapport de
force les conventions d'objectifs mais
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres outils qui
pourrait permettre de mettre les
fédérations en ordre de marche dans de
la prévention au niveau amateur et aussi
sur le sport de haut niveau
merci monsieur bailly j'ai été court
mais j'allais vous féliciter laissez moi
j'attendais ses félicitations et bien
vous allez avoir tout de suite non après
tout administré par le ministère à tous
les instruments nécessaires
le ministère a tous les instruments
nécessaires quand il a fallu quand j'ai
vu que je ne pouvais plus intervenir de
façon douce par rapport à l'époque la
fédération d'haltérophilie
j'ai enlevé l'agrément à la fédération
d'haltérophilie celle arme atomique
il a fallu que la fédération se
reconstruise club par club
bon
sans aller à cette arme atomique vous
avez quand même tout ce qui concerne les
conventions qui sont quand même annuelle
aujourd'hui
donc vous pouvez quand même avoir des
accords avec les fédérations mais j'ai
envie de dire c'est moins le mouvement
sportif français qui n'est pas parfait
loin de là mais en 98-99 le mouvement
sportif français a plutôt eu une très
bonne réaction je rappelle que c'est le
cnosf sous la direction d'henri
sérandour qui organise le rock le relais
des athlètes jusqu'au seuil ou et ça
n'avait pas plu à l'époque au président
ça m'arrange je ne pense pas qu henri
sérandour avait gagné des galons en
faisant ça donc le mouvement sportif
français c'était plutôt impliqué de
bonne façon dans la lutte contre le
dopage
alors c'est inégal certainement sur les
fédérations mais j'ai plutôt ce
sentiment moi je pense que là où nous
avons des difficultés c'est au niveau
des fédérations internationales et comme
c'est elle qui maîtrisent les contrôles
sur toutes les compétitions
internationales
elles sont juges et parties quelques pas
donc c'est ça notre problème
bon c'est pour ça je posais je les
mettais cette proposition de leur
retirer ses contrôles sur la prévention
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on soit
capable de pau organisé moi je crois
c'est que ce partenariat entre le
ministère à l'état on va dire l'état et
le mouvement sportif
une véritable campagne de prévention ce
qu'on a fait certaines époques avec du
matériel adapté aux encadrants aux
jeunes c'était un bon sous je crois que
le mouvement sportif français répondra
présent je le pense profondément
mais ça ne résoudra pas cette pression
des fédérations internationales
merci pour votre réponse à nouveau notre
rapporteur qui a eu l'occasion de
récupérer qui m'attend pleine forme va
reprendre le fil des questions sans être
trop trop long pour nous encore un ou
deux intervenantes
oui toujours sur ce même registre de
l'implication des fédérations je crois
que tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
qu'il faut aller vers davantage
d'implication davantage
responsabilisation des fédérations
sportives sur le
volet prévention est ce que justement il
faut pas faire de coupure nette entre ce
volet prévention et je dirai tout le
reste de la lutte antidopage
l'aspect contrôle aspect répression et
c'est ce qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait une
coupure nette là entre les structures
qui s'occupent de la lutte antidopage et
le mouvement sportif et aussi bien au
niveau national qu'au niveau
international on sait très bien que la
fédération français de tennis par
exemple n'exerce absolument aucune
prérogative en matière de lutte contre
le dopage
c'est la fédération internationale qui
s'occupe du tout deuxièmement tout à
l'heure vous avez rappelé qu
effectivement quand on est en situation
de responsabilité on est sous la
pression permanente de l'opinion
publique
on s'aperçoit que aussi bien d'ailleurs
en matière d'information qui permettent
d'avancer dans la lutte contre le dopage
qu'en matière d'évolution de l'opinion
publique
il y a une influence des sportifs
repenti
on a vu effectivement que c'était les
révélations essentiellement de l'andi
sierre d'hamilton aujourd'hui qui nous
permettent de décoder tout le système
armstrong et je dirais qu'en quelques
mois pratiquement hameçon qui était
d'une icône était devenu un pestiféré
aux états unis ce système d reparti un
système auquel on n'est pas habitué en
france un système américain etc
comment vous voyez si nécessaire une
évolution de la législation française
par rapport à cette question des des
repentis et enfin une troisième et
dernière question madame
vous avez beaucoup insisté sur la
dimension européenne et c'est vrai que
pendant très longtemps on a dit à juste
titre que la france était en avance que
la france était souvent cité comme
modèle comme référence dans cette lutte
antidopage est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui que la france conserve
toujours cette avance là sur les autres
pays
est ce que les autres pays par exemple
sont pas plus efficaces que nous étant
donné l'utilisation à la fin de lutte
contre le dopage de des douanes par
exemple de tout l'arsenal judiciaire etc
oda ministre moi je crains que si nous
faisons une coupure nette en disant aux
fédérations vous si la prévention et
lagence la puissance publique
c'est ce sont les contrôles ce sont les
sanctions
nous allons déresponsabiliser les
fédérations ne peut pas y avoir d'un
côté comme disent les enfants bisounours
fait de la prévention puis donc côté les
méchants qui vont sanctionner
il faut que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités et je pense qu'il faut
que les les hommes et les femmes qui
dirigent les fédérations soient à même
de prendre leurs responsabilités dans
une lutte difficile comme celle contre
me de page ou si on va sur sur les
repentis c'est le questionnement que
j'avais dans mon introduction si on va
dans les repentis donc on est quelque
part il faut des moyens policiers parce
que les repentis c'est pas ça peut être
des repentis qui vont faire ça non mais
des médias etc
après on peut aller dans toutes les
dérives j'ai entendu vos arguments nous
aller aux autres
je penche plutôt de ce côté là d'en
rester aux contrôles donc ça limite la
lapel repenti je constate quand même
dans la sphère lance armstrong qu'il y a
eu deux repentis
un peu plus et que d'un seul coup tout
s'est terminé le grand déballage qui
devait avoir lieu à l'union si triste
l'international des grands
bouleversements qui devait il y avait
même des candidats pour diriger la
fédération à la place de mcquaid sur
lemon tout ça green bouge tout bouge
mais rien ne bouge
je reviens sur la problématique de
ballades dessus de ceux de ce mouvement
sportif qui est fermé en lui-même et qui
donc a tout pouvoir s'il ne veut pas
bouger une bouche pas parce qu'il ya pas
d hier et qui le pousse à le faire alors
sommes nous aujourd'hui toujours le pays
le plus en pointe je n'ai pas les
connaissances
tu n'es pas tu sais maintenant
statistiques aux documents me permettant
de le faire nous sommes partis à 3 à
vrai dire il français nous avons
toujours eu tendance à dire là c'est
nous si j'étais parti seul je me serais
cassé la figure
nous sommes partis à trois le ministre
allemand à l'époque sujet la ministre
italienne qui a eu beaucoup de courage
parce qu elle l avait le coni contre
elle moi j'avais le cnosf avec moi elle
avait le poignet contre elle madame
melandri sommes partis à trois avec des
réticences beaucoup plus affirmée du
côté d'autres pays que je ne citerai pas
pour pas être désagréable qui restent
encore d'ailleurs un petit peu à la
traîne aujourd'hui tous ces pays ont mis
en place des agences tous ces pays ont
mis en place des agences il ya plusieurs
laboratoires qui sont des laboratoires
de hautement qualifiés donc que je vous
je ne ferai pas de jeunes tribus y
aurait pas de médaille d'or ni l'argent
ni de bronze j'en suis bien incapable
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des
pays de l'union européenne sont au même
niveau de la france j'en doute quand
même dans la saturn de pays j'en doute
avez vous des éléments de comparaison
vous nous avez dit que vous avez -
comment je comprends tout à fait mais
existe-t-il selon vous des éléments de
comparaison sur les pays qui vont moins
loin que nous qui sont complètement à la
traîne avons nous des éléments objectifs
pour affirmer cela des éléments
objectifs non je suis incapable moi
personnellement de vous les donner je
pense peut-être que que ce soit dans les
ministères où que ce soit dans les
agences on a ces éléments et que donc
les princes d'autres personnes qui vont
venir témoigner vont pouvoir vous en
faire pas qui fait notre atout en france
on a eu la chance comme tout le monde on
a un laboratoire ce qui n'est pas le cas
tout le monde de qualité avec des gens
tout à fait passionnés et engagés dans
cette lutte
ce qui fait notre force supplémentaire
c'est le rôle que l'état peut jouer par
le partenariat et partage des missions
de service public
c'est pour ça qu'il faut tenir à ce
modèle sportif français qu'on dit
souvent dépassés on fait souvent appel
ou professionnel vous gérez les
fédérations toutes les fédérations
peuvent embaucher des bons
professionnels mais le problème c'est
d'avoir des bons dirigeants de
fédérations ce n'est pas la même chose
voilà donc je pense que ce partenariat
entre le monde sportif et l'état
français c'est le plus que nous avons
par rapport à d'autres pays merci
monsieur mazars vous serez sans doute le
dernier
mais si vous voulez une réponse essayé
de poser une question rapide merci merci
à madame le ministre conclut assister et
à juste titre donc sur l'obligation de
développer une politique de prévention
mais je crois que bien évidemment il
faut aussi la compagnie une politique de
répression
une répression sur le plan du sport avec
des sanctions donc ils doivent être
lourdes
mais est-ce qu'il faut pas aussi essayer
de réfléchir à comment doubler cette
sanction sportive d'une sanction aussi
pourquoi pas pénal mais qu'ils soient
bien bien spécifique peut être à ce type
d'infraction est est-ce qu'il n'ya pas
une réflexion à avoir sur un délit
autonome particulier donc à la tricherie
sportive qui permettrait donc avec des
moyens d'investigation veut d'arriver à
bien établir effectivement qu'elle a été
donc cette règle empreinte non seulement
sur le plan sportif mais également sur
sur le plan des règles qui régissent la
vie en société et sur les moyens
d'investigation moi je joue un petit peu
ce qui a été dit c'est vrai que le
contrôle doit rester le moyen
d'identifier le tricheur sans aucune
difficulté mais peut-être que les autres
moyens d'investigation permettrait
lorsque le tricheur donc et identifier
de bienne personnaliser la sanction qui
sera prononcée contre lui parce qu'il ya
le petit fraîcheur le moyen de tricheur
il ya le gros tricheurs et je crois que
il faut pas effectivement qu'on puisse
les traiter de la même manière je puis
peut-être que ces moyens d'investigation
pour être utile dans le cadre de
sanctions pénales à venir contre le
tricheur mais également contre son
entourage et toutes les complicités
qu'il peut y avoir autour d'un tricheur
parce qu'on sait qu'il agit souvent
parfois contraintes
en tout cas avec une des complicités
donc au sein de sa structure soit
fédéral soit son niveau de son club soit
au niveau de ses coéquipiers donc ça me
paraît très important mois que par des
moyens d'investigation appartement où on
a identifié le tricheur on puisse aller
au delà et chercher des responsabilités
pénales donc concernant tout tout tout
son entourage
et puis les victimes se sont d'abord
effectivement souvent les sportifs même
elle même qui le somme mais il ya aussi
les spectateurs et téléspectateurs
c'est-à-dire ceux qui paient leur entrée
dans les stades ceux qui passent leur
après midi
tout au long du mois du juillet donc à
regarder les étapes du tour geek et
finalement au bout alors dit ben non
mais finalement les dés étaient pipés et
ce pour quoi vous êtes enthousiasmé tout
ça vous oubliez ça reste plus dans mon
rêve parce que ce n'était pas la vraie
vie ce n'est pas vrai la vraie réalité
et c'est vrai que bon c'est vrai qu'en
france et class action tout ça c'est pas
possible mais c'est vrai qu'on pouvait
se poser la question de savoir si on
m'en donne et on pourrait pas faire
rembourser de façon très conséquente
pour le coup s'il y avait un intérêt à
agir pour beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup le
téléspectateur ou de spectateurs floués
contre des organisateurs qui ont gagné
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent avec un
système dont les dés étaient pipés et
dont il ne pouvait ignorer voilà donc
tous âges parce que ce sont des pistes
de réflexion mais je crois que sur le
plan pénal il ya peut-être quelque chose
à réfléchir sur un délit bien
spécifiques avec des intérêts à agir
pour beaucoup de victimes de faits
tricherie merci madame la ministre
monsieur le président je me permets de
vous dire que si vous voulez rajouter
quelque chose au-delà des questions
puisque nous arrivons au tertiaire de
notre entretien
donc d'abord je voudrais dire que nous
avons travaillé des 98 99
je rappelle que l'on dit toujours la loi
99 mais c'est dans votre haute assemblée
que la loi a d'abord été adopté et lors
du tour de france 98 la loi était déjà
passée au sénat puisque je me rappelle
avoir été convoqués à matignon
et ben on va questionner sur le fait
mais est ce que j'allais tenir est ce qu
on allait et je leur ai rappelé qu'à loi
était passé et donc maintenant nous
étions tenus par la loi d'aller jusqu'au
bout mais en 98 au tour de france ce
n'est pas ce qui déclenche toute la
sphère c'est bien parce que justement il
ya une collaboration avec d'autres
services
les douanes nous avions mis des cellules
régionales avec les douanes avec eux
santé jeunesse et sports douanes pour
justement essayer d'agir par d'autres
biais aussi ben voilà et aujourd'hui
existe je pense je ne suis pas une
spécialiste du juridique mais existent
les moyens de poursuivre quelqu'un qui
fait le trafic de produits illicites qui
recèle des produits illicites qui vend
ses produits etc
donc on a quand même des moyens de
rattraper un certain nombre de personnes
dans l'encadrement on peut être
poursuivi pour pratique illégale de la
médecine par exemple il ya des médecins
ses longues boucles en procès arrive
quand même c'est très long où est né ce
qui se passe en espagne c'est très très
long alors sur le spectateur floués si
l'organisateur est convaincu d'être au
courant du dopage
il va aussi enlevé de poursuites pénales
alors faut regarder ici chacun de ces
cas et gouverne faut vérifier
faut-il ajouter une sanction pénale aux
sportifs sanctionnés
ma conviction est que non quand vous
êtes un sportif de haut niveau
professionnel ou amateur
même si aujourd'hui mais beaucoup de
sport ou sport de haut niveau y compris
amateurs dépend aussi du sponsoring etc
vous êtes violemment sonné pour vous
êtes arrêté de pratiquer pendant deux
ans et que vous perdez tous vos points
d'appui la sanction est déjà lourde
mesurant bien ce que ça représente pour
un sportif qui est pris en plein milieu
de sa carrière sportive
les conséquences que ça pour lui ou pour
elle donc je ne suis pas à moi qu'il
fasse du recel à moins qu'ils soient
convaincus d'avoir forcé d'autres
équipiers d'autres sportifs à se doper
là ça relève du pénal mais moi je suis
pour le sportif simplement pris sur le
contrôle positif sans autres chefs
d'accusation d'en rester à la sanction
sportive je le rappelle c'est lourd
c'est lourd pour un pour un sportif
non la seule chose je voudrais ajouter
monsieur le président si vous puisque
vous me l'autorisé
c'est d'insister sur un fait qui ne
dépend pas de la loi c'est la parole
publique
je le redis je les dis dans mon
introduction tous les acteurs de la
lutte contre le dopage à quelques
niveaux qu'ils soient ont besoin de se
sentir soutenu c'est une lutte ingrate
quelque part vous détruisez des beaux
bijoux vous détruisez des moments de
fête populaire vous décevez quelques pas
donc il faut que ces acteurs de la lutte
contre le dopage se sentent soutenus par
l'autorité publique et je crois que
voilà il faut qu' il faut l'entendre
beaucoup plus la parole publique sur ces
questions je pense que ça permettra
peut-être si vous pensez que nous avons
de nouveau pris un peu de retard de
repartir avec je l'espère toutes les
compositions que vous allez nous faire
vous après les conclusions de votre
commission denquête merci madame la
ministre
pour cette excellente intervention la
commission aura l'occasion de se
repencher sur ce que nous avons dit
entendu aujourd'hui
merci d'avoir répondu et de l'avoir fait
très franchement merci merci à vous
voilà pour ces auditions de la
commission d' enquête sur le dopage si
vous souhaitez les revoir elles sont
disponibles en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très bonne
journée à tous